okay so how many requirements do you
have for a guy that you're gonna date
um
i don't know a few do you have like a
height requirement
i would say
i mean taller than me okay so maybe like
i mean i'm five seven so
anything taller than that okay because
i'm not really picky honestly so
okay do you have like um like a major
requirement like would you be cool with
a guy that had like any major here yeah
seven or ten do you have like a religion
they have to be the same religion like
anything like that uh this is a
christian school that's why i asked yeah
do you think that women are too picky
yeah why
they can't make up their mind
what do you mean
um
they're like
i don't think i'm the right person to
interview nobody
um
[Music]
do they go back and forth a lot they do
they really do do you feel like women
actually want the nice guy
no
no i don't think so what do you think
the biggest mistake girls make in dating
oh
the biggest mistake girls make yeah
choosing the wrong guy
you think they go for the bad boy
uh
depends on the girl but maybe usually do
you think that men and women can be
friends
yes
why
because i have
male friends that's anecdotal evidence
but do you think that they secretly just
want to date you
no because i have a boyfriend oh really
yeah do you think they're just like
waiting in case like something happens
no do you think men and women can be
friends absolutely why because like
men need men friends girls need
girlfriends
and they also need men and girlfriends
do you think do you have female friends
i do have female friends yes do you
think any of them are ugly
yes wow okay
what i shouldn't have mine name them
name them
do you think that women are too picky
[Music]
what do you mean like when they're
selecting like a partner do you think
they're too picky
it depends on the girls some are too
picky and some are not picky at all
yeah i think some are too picky because
they're like they like complain about
how they want a boyfriend but i'm sure
there's a lot of dudes that they could
like
they could get with if they wanted to do
you wanna know an interesting stat sure
so out of single men 20 of single men
have sexual access to 80 of women does
that make sense with what you've seen
no
i know wheaton might be different i
don't know how lean does that cute she
said again 20 of single men have sexual
access to 80 percent of women
so so like for example only 15 percent
of so only 15 of them on youtube bro
like for
for example only 15 percent of men are
over six foot
like that's like a stat like most people
think like
that six foot isn't like crazy tall but
that's actually like top 15 percent of
that
[Music]
hey shout out to the short king
okay do you think that men and women can
be friends
yes why
uh
because we're all human and
i typically you can be friends as humans
i suppose
if the assumption is always that you're
like interested in them then it makes it
difficult but
i don't know i've got lots of friends
that are female that i
i don't i think there's a shared mutual
understanding like we're friends yeah
and of course not to say that something
could happen and things would change but
yeah no that's oh that's very
interesting do you think that men and
women can be friends yes why
um because god created
man and woman to be able to uh
cohabitate so
created man and woman so probably i mean
they can be friends